[Music]
what has been your biggest learning in
creating all of this shiny for python
magic oh man
biggest learning
so much
a lot of different components involved
in building this stuff there was
building shiny for python itself which
was a really good learning experience i
hadn't really done a whole lot of python
programming before but uh having that
having the opportunity to like implement
shiny again has been really interesting
and sort of you know it's given us a lot
of chances to think about like hey how
do we do we really want to really want
to do things this way can we do things a
better way in with this web stuff
there's so much javascript programming
and typescript
for programming
and just learning what the possibilities
are here has been super fun and it's
it's it's been it's been really exciting
to sort of like
push the boundaries of what's possible i
feel like you know we're using stuff
right now that's sort of at the edge of
uh of what's possible like hey i wanna i
wanna build something what i wish i had
was something that system that did this
and and then being able to go and build
that that's been that's really fun i
feel like it's juggling all the pieces
like in making the transition from
exploration to shiny like knowing when
to stop exploring the data and to move
it into a shiny app and also like just
how to get auto complete for everything
has been really helpful a lot of people
think about writing in vs code and you
can do it like in a notebook in vs code
too but i think the reason notebooks are
so useful is that oftentimes i want to
auto complete like data too
and that's not like a static analysis
you can't just like sit down with a
script and autocomplete the columns of
your data so to me it's been that dance
of like auto completing the names of
columns and stuff and being able to
build an app
that's a really weird actually i think
uniquely data science
space it's hard to
put yourself in the shoes of the users
of something like this
by definition you are someone writing
this app
you have experience and you're not you
know boots on the ground writing these
apps every day and so it's very easy to
forget what's important and to
prioritize the wrong things the biggest
like long-term learning thing has been
not trust
my immediate intuition about what is the
most important thing to prioritize
development because i'm probably wrong
as a data scientist i
still think that r is you know is very
much my tool of choice if i'm doing that
kind of work where i'm like working with
a new data set
trying to find interesting things from
it but coming to python and you know now
my day job being more of a software
engineer where
i'm the one responsible
for
creating the software that data
scientists will then use it's been a
really nice experience coming into
python and
there being all of these kind of really
mature
sophisticated libraries for building
kind of the foundational piece of what
you would need for a framework like
shiny and not only that but using vs
code with things like github copilot and
just like the integrations with
navigating large python
code bases in vs code and all the like
the extension ecosystem and provides a
really rich experience for you know
navigating through large code bases and
learning python